See you're here in New York with me.
And it's interesting
because David mentioned the 2020
the fellow 2024 candidates
or some that may be candidates
and haven't announced yet.
I think we have a graphic
that shows some of their reactions.
We know that vice president former
Vice President Pence was on our air.
He said that
no one should be above the law
but he criticized
this case
DeSantis called it
a quote weaponization
of the legal system.
Nikki Haley saying
this is more about revenge than justice
and so on and so forth.
How do they thread the needle here
and what do you do
if you're a potential rival?
Because you need the base support.
But at the same time, this is a chance
to kind of needle
a Donald Trump with all the baggage
that he brings. Right.
I think you let the court
of public opinion do that for you.
I think if you're running against
against Donald Trump.
David Chalian is right.
The field frozen.
There's really nowhere for them to go.
You're not going to win
any voters on the right.
And we're still in a primary
by applauding
this decision or
dunking on Donald Trump right now.
So I think they're doing the right thing.
But I think when it comes to the politics
of this, it's really important
to remember.
I think I think that this indictment
is coming in spite of politics
because if you were trying to orchestrate
a political takedown of Donald Trump,
you wouldn't start with this charge
but also, it's important
to look at the people who are outraged.
Right.
The folks running against Donald Trump.
The Tucker
Carlson's
the Fox News is
the Republican Trump surrogates
These are people who are outraged
by this indictment.
They were not outraged
by Trump's attempt
to overturn a Democratic election.
They were not outraged by the violence
on January six.
They were not outraged
by an illegal phone
call to the Georgia secretary of state,
an illegal phone
call to Volodymyr Zelensky.
They're not outraged by multiple credible
accusations of sexual harassment,
assault and rape.
They're not outraged
by Trump's sexist, bigoted,
homophobic, xenophobic, rhetoric.
They're not outraged
by his white nationalism.
They're not outraged by his defense
of anti-Semitism and neo-Nazis.
They're not outraged by all that stuff.
So with all due respect,
no one should care
that these people are outraged
by this indictment.
Former Vice
President Mike Pence,
who could be Trump's opponent
in this 2024 race,
also speaking out
on the criminal charges,
calling them targeted and unjustified.
Listen.
Well, I think
the unprecedented indictment
of a former president
of the United States on a campaign
finance issue is an outrage.
And it appears
to for millions of Americans
to be nothing more
than a political prosecution
that's driven
by a prosecutor
who literally ran for office on a pledge
to indict the former president.
And our guests are back with us, Norm
Eisen, David Chalian, S.E.
Cupp. S.E., I want to start with you.
Go back to Marjorie Taylor,
Greene planning
to come to New York City to protest.
We've seen
House GOP leadership rush
to former President Trump's defense.
We have not heard anything
from Senate
leadership, Senate GOP leadership
that really drives home this wedge
and this divide between
Kevin McCarthy, Mitch McConnell,
two types of Republicans that are left.
And yet we were talking during the break
when these Senate Republicans
had the opportunity
and they're the only ones, mind you,
that can bar him from running again
by vote,
convicting him during that impeachment.
They didn't take it. Yeah.
What does this tell you
about where the Republican Party is
right now?
Well, I think on the Senate side,
there are a number of Republicans
who are ready to move on
from Donald Trump.
On the House side,
I think they still very much
want to be where Donald Trump
and that energy is.
But I don't see
anyone really willing to move on
from Donald Trump's voters.
And that's what you have to do.
It's one thing to just say
Donald Trump was bad for us
and bad for a party.
That's obvious.
The math is there.
It's another to say.
And we're willing to say no
to the kinds of voters
that he courted
so that he could win
the White Nationalists,
the Oath Keepers, the Q
and on the conspiracy theorists,
the bigots,
this wing of the Republican Party
that Donald Trump said, come one, come
all previous
Republican parties would say,
you're not welcome here.
I'm not going to court you.
I'm not going to pretend
I don't know who you are
until this Republican Party
is ready to do that.
They're really just allowing Trump
to loom large and keep all of those kinds
of voters inside the tent at the expense
of good conservatives
like Adam Kinzinger, Liz Cheney,
who they've kicked out
yeah.
David Chalian, we
were speaking earlier in the break
about what followed the FBI
search of the Trump home
a number of weeks ago.
And that was a
the shooter attacked an FBI office
in Cincinnati.
This is something that that
is of great concern
to security officials.
Here.
Now, we will have a president indicted.
He's already indicted
and have to surrender next week.
What should folks
watching here,
what level of concern
should they have about a violent reaction
to this?
Well, we know the reporting
is that you noted
law enforcement officials,
security officials
have been engaged in conversations
for a couple of weeks now
about trying to quell any such violence
and being prepared for it.
Obviously, we saw the former
president call
for protest
of his anticipated indictment.
He even suggested that
there would be death and destruction
if indeed he is indicted now.
Mike Pence,
just to note, in that interview
last night
with Wolf Blitzer,
while he called
this indictment outrageous,
he did say that rhetoric of Donald Trumps
is out of bounds
and that that is totally unacceptable.
Rhetoric.
And so we
we will watch as New York
prepares for this moment on Tuesday.
Marjorie Taylor Greene
tweeting that she's
going to go there and join in a protest
to me would be an immediate
level of concern of a high profile member
with a following.
How large does a potential protest come
This is something for security
officials to watch.
But you're right to note
what happened over
the summer in the aftermath of that.
And and obviously,
this is not something
that anybody would hope would happen.
But it seems that the security officials
are engaged
in very real conversations
about dealing with it, if it does.
Right?
It is. It's very, very serious.
Norm,
I want to go back to you for one second,
because I think it's
worth reminding people
Donald Trump can still run for president
and be president
if he is indicted, which he has been.
And even if he's been convicted, right?
No,
that's absolutely correct.
We have parallels in American history.
Eugene Debs,
the Socialist candidate, is one.
And the reality is that ultimately
the criminal case will be decided
by a jury in New York.
The political case will be decided
by the jury of the American people.
They have spoken in 20, 20
and in 20, 22, rejecting
some of the extreme
ideologies, the election denial
and some of the other extreme
ideologies associated with Donald Trump.
But they're going to
have to take into account
not just this criminal case,
but we're very likely
to see additional ones
coming down the pike.
I think Georgia may very well be next.
And of course,
we saw the Mike Pence clip,
the special counsel
in DOJ's investigation
is trying to get Pence's testimony.
Other individuals are being pursued.
That's on the January six case.
And then you have the Mar a Lago
documents case.
So four major criminal cases potentially
will overhang this political season,
providing judicial challenges,
but also
asking every American voter
to sit in judgment.
Right.
And decide where they come down on this.
There's so much more to come legally.
All right, Norm Eisen, S.E.
Cupp, David Chalian,
we appreciate all three of you
and your analysis here. Thanks so much.